let's be honest for many the thought of
cycling in a city is terrifying
you could get bored or hit by a bus if
you were cyclists in New York City in
the 2000 it was almost like you were a
cast member from Escape from New York we
people were maybe an extreme sport
person it was fantastic for you because
you were dodging cars it was you know
not a place to have you know any kind of
safe commuting regular transport
experience but today New York City is
seeing explosive growth in cycle
commutes so how did the city with
traffic like this get so many people
biking downtown
from 2007 to 2013 jeanette Sadiq Khan
led New York City's Department of
Transportation I was in charge of 6000
miles of streets 789 bridges 12,000
signalized intersections 1.3 million
street signs
we put down 400 miles of on-street bike
lanes including one of the first parking
protected bike lanes in the United
States and we did it on 9th Avenue
between 23rd Street and 16th Street this
Lane was significant because it was an
early parking protected design it's much
less stressful than conventional lanes
but installing it was quite
controversial because making the space
for protected lanes meant the
elimination of parking taking away
parking spaces is not for the faint of
heart and there is no super-secret you
know magic recipe that's going to make
it easier to do but you need to make the
case about what you are trying to do
right the ninth Avenue pilot ran for six
blocks and if you look at the blueprint
for the street you'll notice an
alternating pattern on blocks with
right-hand turns there's an entire lane
of parking
but at left turns those parking spots
are sacrificed for a barrier the
vehicles will wait next to the bike lane
here and separate signals for cars and
bikes stager to reduce the stress at the
intersection data show that the 9th
avenue bike lane produced economic
mobility and safety benefits we saw
crashes go down from 47% retail sales
went up almost 49% cars had dedicated
turn lanes so the traffic process much
better and bikes had a dedicated lane so
it was a win for business it was a win
for drivers was a win for people on foot
and it was winning for people on two
wheels and that really set the stage for
all that followed once the city analyzed
data from the 9th Avenue pile
the miles of protected Lane in New York
skyrocketed by 2018 the city had nearly
1,200 miles of bike lane and 100 of
those were protected because we weren't
going to accommodate a million more
people by just double decking our
streets and highways and so designing
streets for people that they get easier
to buy it and easier to walk it easier
to take the bus
that's the kind of recipe for future
success of cities and the cities that
make these kinds of investments and
changes are the cities that are growing
and thriving in the century but to
really draw a crowd of cyclists a city
needs a network of low stress bike lanes
you can't just paint sharrows on a
street and expect that people are gonna
while lost start biking it needs to be a
reliable system and it needs to be safe
and the way that we look at the health
of our bike lanes and a bike lane
network is how many women and children
are using the lanes because when when
you see women and kids in the lanes and
families in the lanes you know that it's
safe families among other individuals
would fall into the interested but
concerned group on this chart it's from
a survey taken in Oregon but consensus
in the transportation field suggests
that this group is the untapped
potential for cities who want to promote
cycling which is the big factor behind
New York's boom in urban cyclists and it
was pretty cost-effective you know the
bike lanes were like 99% of our
headlines but they were only 1% of the
budget so I don't think there's a better
investment if you want to build a better
city you can start by building bike
lanes
[Music]